Шановні колеги пане рустеме за чотири
злишні роки цього
парламенту європейська Солідарність
жодного разу не голосувала за кадрові
призначення це принципова позиція
Оскільки Влада має нести
відповідальність а меншість повинна мати
можливість контролювати дії
влади але 24 лютого змінило
все Я згадую цей день В цьому
залі і за різними обставинами Хто за
патріотизму Хто за люті Хто за
остраху але країна
об'єдналася далі були різні голосування
ми були завжди єдині в підтримки воєнних
законів бо це не про політику це про
державу
України Я Хочу наголосити що це перше
подання після 24го міністра
оборони у нас величезні претензії до
попереднього міністра незважаючи на те
що він Я його дуже добре знаю починаючи
ще з революції
помаранчевою але претензії не тільки в
корупції не в куртках не в яйцях не в
закупівлі
озброєння претензії в підготовці сть
місяців підготовці до
війни за яких ми зараз платимо величезну
ціну на жаль
це так але єдність нам
потрібна і на сьогоднішній день Навіть
розуміючи всі проблеми з цим
призначенням бо Рустем немає воєнного
досвіду але він блискучий менеджер і Я
впевнений що ключові функції
Міністерства оборони а саме про
транспарентне і ефективне забезпечення
збройних сил України він витягне а
єдність у нас має бути не навколо
корумпованих
політиків не навколо політичних партій
або особистості єдність у нас має бути
навколо українського воїна збройних сил
України і це
важливо і ще одна позиція Я пишаюся тим
що представники міжліса ходиться саме в
європейській солідарності і призначення
кримського татарина сьогодні міністром
оборони дуже потужний меседж що ніяких
домовленостей без Криму
неможливо і третя
позиція для мене дуже важливо щоби не
тільки негативний а й позитивний досвід
був рустема подивитися на полторака це
важні уроки Дякую і слава Україні